Musik Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Wo kommt das her, dass man das die ganze Zeit wiederholen muss? Ich weiß es nicht, diese ganze Jahrmarktästhetik hat mich nie erwischt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das hat mich immer eher abgeturnt. Ja, dass du sprichst, zufällig zu nah an den Lautsprecher und dann kommt so eine nächste Runde rückwärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, wärts, w, hey, hey, oh komm, lass uns da mitfahren. Lass uns da hin, lass uns in die Richtung dieses Geräusches gehen mehr. Ich glaube, wenn ich eine Achterbahn werfen würde, ich würde die absichtlich so niedlich wie es geht nennen, einfach nur, damit ich irgendwann mal die Schlagzeile sehe, 16 Kinder sterben an Genickbruch im fröhlichen Raupenparadies. Ja, im Räublein, im kleinen Räublein. In der kleinen hungrigen Raupe, 16 Kinder durch Erquetschungen. Durch Erquetschungen und furchtbare Enthauptungen im kleinen Räublein. Erquetschung ist, glaube ich, der schlimmste Tod, den man sterben kann. Es gibt viele schlimme Tode, aber ich glaube, erquetscht werden. Ich glaube, das ist eines der schlimmsten Wörter, weil es gibt es gar nicht. Ich glaube, es gibt wenig gute Wörter, die R als Vorsilbe haben. Ertrinken, Erbrennen, Erquetschen, es gibt nur Schlechtes. Erstmal vielen Dank an L Max für das Intro. Völlig richtig, das ist eine gute Vorsilbe, Al ist gut. Al Max, vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro. Und vielen Dank an alle Leute, die kommentiert haben, um mal wieder dem Heerenziel, Stefan Tietze zu entkleiden, ihn als das, was er ist, darzustellen, als fadenscheinigen Hochstapler, als leere Hülle, die mit nichts gefüllt ist, als hohler Mensch. Wieso kommst du jetzt darauf, dass die Leute mich entkleiden wollen? Der hohle Mensch, die Leute zeigen, halten dir den Spiegel vor, du nämlich letzte Folge posaunst raus und sagst hier, ich bin der tolle Lutz, guckt mich an, mit einer steilen These, dass es nur in Italien deutsche Namen für Städte gibt. Und die Community hat einfach mal schön, also wirklich dieses, naja, was ist denn mit hier, Barcelona, dem und dem, Mailand, Warschau, soll ich mehr nennen? Ja, also wirklich mit einem solchen Überfluss an Gegenargumenten, die ich einfach begraben habe. Barcelona heisst Barcelona. Ja, war ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber es gibt genug Begriffe, es gibt genug Namen. Ich werde 90 Prozent, ich nehme es nochmal auf mit euch, 90 Prozent kammern die Banken mit, ja, das war jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil, ja, Warschau, okay, got it. Ja, Lisboa, Lissabon, sowas, ja, also da gibt es viele Sachen, die genannt haben. Es gibt schon sehr viele Ausnahmen. Aber wirklich, aber alle Kommentare mit so einem und viele mehr, punkt, punkt, punkt, so wie dieses soll ich weitermachen, soll ich, ich habe 300 Gegenargumente, Stefan Tietze, ich nenne dir mal drei und dann gucken wir, wie viel wir noch brauchen. Guck mal, was von dir kommt zurück, ob du einlenken willst schon oder ob, ne, ich kämpfe noch eine Runde. Nee, ich hab genug. Also ich hab wirklich den ganzen Tag, könnte ich den Namen nennen. Gut, ich ändere es. Wir sind ja lernfähig.
Ja.
Ich sage dann mal, ich mache daraus These.
Gut. Das Land, in dem die meisten Städte deutsch umbenannt werden, ist Italien. Okay. Aber hat irgendwer da was dazu gesagt? Oder war das mehr so ein, das war so grauenhafter Bullshit, wir antworten erst gar nicht auf seine Ausgangsfrage? Das war ein so schlechtes Argument, dass eigentlich die Wörter verschwendet werden. Die haben einfach das Geografiebuch aufgemacht, auf eine Seite so zweimal getippt und sind dann gegangen, haben dann den Raum verlassen. Das war das Geräusch. Das war das Geräusch. Das war das Geräusch. Man muss da gar nicht viel dazu sagen. Das heißt, die Frage, warum es ausgerechnet in Italien ist, wurde gar nicht erst beantwortet, weil es hinfällig ist. Weil es hinfällig ist. Weil hinlängställig ist. Ja, hinfällig und ja, also da wurde Stefan Tietze debunkt, aber auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, Stefan Tietze, du hast was erlebt? Ich bin, das ist hilarious. Also, erstmal vielen Dank an die Rocket Beans für diese tolle Einladung. Ich durfte gegen Fabian Krane, fantastischer Kollege von dem von von Rocket Beans, durfte ich in der Sendung Lach und Schachgeschichten von dem grossartigen Gustav Sonnen, Grossmeister im Schach, durfte ich meinem Hobby, meinem neu gewonnenen Hobby nachgehen. Ich glaube, es kam im Podcast gar nicht so durch, dass du die letzten Wochen intensiv Schach gespielt hast, aber es war immer so, nach der Aufnahme sage ich immer noch so, hey, wollen wir noch was trinken gehen, uns nochmal zusammensetzen, die Folge nochmal Review passieren lassen und du mal, nee, nee, ich muss Schach, ich muss Schach spielen, ich muss schnell weg. Denn das habt ihr verpasst, Florentin will mit mir mal ein Trinken gehen jetzt nach der Folge und ich sage immer, nein, ich will lieber Schach spielen. Genau. Das ist also, wir haben uns diametral in andere Richtungen entwickelt und ich möchte eigentlich nicht so gerne selber Lob zuschustern, sondern ich möchte euch einfach ein Audioclip vorspielen. Von wem ist das? Von Rustam Kasimdjanow, ein ehemaliger Schachweltmeister, zählt als der beste Schachtrainer der Welt, trainiert auch aktuell die Nummer zwei der Welt Fabiano Caruana und der hat das zusammen mit Jan Gustafsson über mich gesagt. Ich habe Stefan Tietze gesehen heute. Stefan ist wahrscheinlich der begabteste Spieler der Geschichte, ja? Zwei Monate spielt er Schach. Das ist nicht möglich. Sagt Rustam, der begnadeteste Spieler der Geschichte. Vor allem, man muss sagen, das wurde ja gesagt in der Sendung von dem Publikum, das dich nicht kennt. Also es ergibt wenig Sinn, hier Gags zu machen. Und in der Sendung, wo ich verloren habe. Das ist ja, wo Fabian mich zweimal besiegt hat. Ich konnte eine Partie für mich entscheiden. Aber ich bin der begnadetste Spieler der Geschichte. Wahrscheinlich der begnadetste Spieler der Geschichte. Der Geschichte. Ich habe mich so darüber gefreut, ich bin den ganzen Tag aus dem Häuschen. Jetzt muss man sagen, also ich verstehe nicht genau, es kann natürlich ein Witz sein und es ist höchstwahrscheinlich, es ist ein trockener Humor.
Aber es ist der falsche Kontext für einen Witz, die Zuschauer würden das nicht verstehen.
Kontext, das hat er ja auch dann auch nochmal zu einer, zu Sonja, ich verheirte den Nachnamen leider nicht, einer anderen Moderatorin gesagt, die hat nämlich heute zusammen Schach kommentiert und da fiel auch noch mal ein ähnlicher Satz, den ich euch natürlich auch nicht vorenthalten will. Aber ich bin so stolz gerade, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Vor allem, es würde ja als Gag nur Sinn ergeben, wenn du schlecht gespielt hättest, aber du hast ja wirklich gut gespielt. Also es ergibt gar keinen Sinn, als Gag zu sagen, du bist der begabteste Spieler der Geschichte. So, auch schon Nummer zwei. Das war teilweise so richtig beeindruckend. Und Jan erzählte mir das, der Stefan, der spielt erst seit ein paar Monaten Schach. Und dafür, soweit ich sehen kann, so überweite Strecken der Partie spielte, so auf dem Niveau zwischen so zwei, vier, zwei, fünf. Und ich verstehe nicht, wie das möglich ist. Also das ist irgendwie unfassbar. Also ich weiss nicht, wie ihr das hinkriegt. Ihr Talent. Unfassbar. Also irgendwie ist es mir gelungen, ich fühle mich fast schuldig, dass es mir irgendwie gelungen ist, in diesen paar Partien, die ich verloren habe, den Anschein zu erwecken, als wäre ich gut in diesem Spiel. Ich habe mich da natürlich ein bisschen reingefuchst und vielleicht erkenne ich auch mittlerweile schon mehr Muster und so und werde auch besser. Das gehe ich schon auch aus. Bescheidenheit ist ein hohes Gut. Weiss nicht. Aber nicht jetzt. Du bist der beste Spieler der Geschichte, der beste Schachspieler der Geschichte und dein Talent ist unfassbar. Nicht nur bist du der beste Spieler der Geschichte, du bist es auch in nur zwei Monaten geworden. Also du bist... Nee, nee, ich glaube, das ist das Verhältnis, was er genau meint. Ich glaube, er meint, in dem Verhältnis, er spielt erst zwei Monate so gut, in diesem Paket bin ich der begnadete Spieler der Geschichte des Schachsports. Also ich weiß es nicht, weil folgendes Szenario. Ich habe jetzt den armen Rustam, auch super netter Kerl, unfassbar toll, den habe ich jetzt so verarschen können mit meinen scheinbaren Skills, dass ich nur mal so eine Fantasie, dass er jetzt Fabiano Caruana sagt, Nummer zwei der Welt, mit dir werde ich gerade offensichtlich Nummer eins der Welt. Ich lasse jetzt alles auf Stefan, weil der macht das ganz gut. Vielleicht ist es so ein bisschen das Äquivalent von so diesen amerikanischen Basketball- Halbzeit-Shows, wo Zuschauer den Basketball von dem anderen Spielfeldrand werfen und einer schafft es, auf dem ersten Wurf den zu versenken und die Leute sagen, das ist der begabteste Spieler aller Zeiten. Es wird nie wieder ein grösseres Talent geben als diesen Spieler, der einfach einmal und danach auch nie wieder gespielt hat. Nur einmal diesen Wurf und er geht einfach in die Hall of Fame an als der beste Talent, die grösste Nachwuchshoffnung des Basketball-Sports. Genauso ist es bei dir auch, so eine sehr kleine Stichprobe, wo du gut brilliert hast. Ich habe das Stolz meiner Mutter erzählt und die hat auch sofort gesagt, weil ich war damals mal für eine Woche in einer Schach-AG und die hat dann sofort gesagt, warum bist du da nicht drin geblieben? Das wurde direkt so vorwurfsvoll. Warum hast du da nie was draus gemacht, wenn das offensichtlich dein Talent ist? Und ich war direkt in so Defensive, in so einer, nee sorry, ich wollte dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ein paar Freunde sind dann da rausgetreten und dann wollte ich auch nicht mehr weitermachen. Es ist schwer, Eltern zufrieden zu stellen. Ja, wenn der beste Schachträger der Welt sagt, ich bin der begrenztenste Spieler der Geschichte und selbst dann kommt, er warst nicht in der Schach AG länger als eine Woche, dann weiß ich auch nicht genau. Aber wirst du jetzt dieses...
Arrogant abheben?
Ja, abheben, das ist ja schon passiert.
Aber wirst du jetzt dieses enorme Talent weiter ausbauen oder sagst du, ach nö, du lässt es so nebenbei, ach ja, ich bin die begabteste Talente der Geschichte, aber naja.
Wir haben das ja schon ein paar Mal hinlänglich beobachtet bei mir, dass ich meine Phasen habe.
Und da bin ich sehr begeisterungsfähig und ich kann mich dann auch gewisserweise sehr gut immer dafür so sehr begeistern, dass ich mich dann so reinfuchsen kann in Themen. Jetzt ist es mir noch nie passiert, dass ich mich so gut in etwas reinfuchsen konnte, dass der weltbeste Ben-Trainer in diesem Bereich sagt, ich bin der begleitete Typ. Obwohl, das wissen wir nicht. Du hattest ja noch eine Posaunephase. Und eine Kochphase. Vielleicht bist du auch der beste Posaunistentalent der Geschichte. Es hat nur nie jemand zu Gehör bekommen, der das einschätzen könnte. Was wenn ich alles immer in der Phase, in der ich mich begeistern kann, sehr gut kann. Und dann verliere ich aber immer das Interesse, was mich dann im Endeffekt zu einem schlechten Menschen macht. Ja. Weil ich nutze das Talent, was ich dann... Ich glaube aber, das sagt auch aus, dass es nur um Motivation geht und um Begeisterungsfähigkeit. Ich glaube, wenn man nämlich richtig Bock auf etwas hat, dann ist man auch bereit, da alles reinzulegen und sich reinzufuchsen und die Masterclass mit Gary Kasparov draufzuschauen. Dann läuft es doch. Ey, solange es eine Masterclass gibt über ein Thema, bin ich sehr bereit, der Beste der Geschichte zu werden, egal in was. Tennis kommt auch noch bald. Aber fände ich sehr cool, wenn dieser Grossmeister dich jetzt an die Hand nimmt und dich ausbilden will. Und dann merkt. Und merkt. Scheiße, ich habe mich hier. Das ist auch eine geile Serie. Eigentlich so ein junges, aufstrebendes Terren, so Searching for Bobby Fischer mässig. Irgendwie wird er irgendwie so aus dem Washington Park rausgecastet, du bist ein Talent und dann kann er halt einfach nix. Und dann muss der Film gucken, wie er zurecht kommt. Ja, weil er durch Zufall in drei Partien ganz okay gespielt hat.
Genau und dann, okay, ich zahle ihn so viel, der Mutter wird 100.000 Euro gegeben, dass sie das Kind weggegeben wird oder so und dann fliegt es nach Russland und soll ausgebildet werden und kriegt halt einfach nichts mehr auf die Reihe. Und dann muss der Film halt gucken, wie er weitermacht, ob man dann noch irgendwie so eine Coming-of-Age-Geschichte erzählt.
Aber man merkt dem Film sehr an, dass er weitermacht, ob man dann noch irgendwie so eine Coming-of-Age-Geschichte erzählt.
Aber man merkt dem Film sehr an, dass es lieber hätte, dass der jetzt erfolgreich ist, weil dann könnte man eine bessere Geschichte erzählen. Aber er verliert leider die Spiele halt. Und es ist schon so die Musik, der Aufbau und dann leider verloren. Auch weil der gleiche Montagesong häufig ist versucht. Also er kommt doch mal durch. Er versucht es immer zu pushen, der Film versucht immer so, komm du schaffst es, aber nee. Ja sorry, ich habe halt komplett die Dame übersehen. Scheiße. Und ich finde vor allem aber die traurigste Gestaltung in dieser ganzen Geschichte ist Fabian Krane, der gegen mich gewonnen hat, aber nicht als der begeisterte. Ich glaube wirklich, Rostam meint das im Sinne von, ich bin noch nicht so lang. Ja,ian spielt auch noch nicht so lang. Ist aber auch witzig, ne? Also das funktioniert schon auch gut als Prank, wenn du verlierst und dann Rostam einfach 20 Minuten lang dich lobt, während Fabian gerade kaum erwähnt wird. Das ist wirklich eine der grössten Talente, die ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe. Grossartig. Du hast verloren. Wie Office-Kamera-Blake dieses. Ja, hat schon gut gespielt. Also ich bin so froh, diese Erfahrung machen zu dürfen und ich werde auf jeden Fall dranbleiben zu meiner Frage, ob ich weitermachen will oder nicht. Doch, ich habe schon Bock. Schach macht unglaublich viel Spaß mir. Aber jetzt hast du natürlich einen hohen Erwartungsdruck, weil jetzt ist der gerade Höhenflug und jetzt musst du ja eigentlich delivern und das könntest du dir ersparen, indem du sagst, nee, jetzt ist der Höhepunkt, jetzt hänge ich meinen Läufer an den Nagel und lasse es. Das ist das Pferd? Nee, das ist der Spitzmeister, der Spitze, der hat doch so eine Kerbe drin. Bishop. Und jetzt könntest du wirklich am Höhepunkt aufhören, ich glaube, es ist ein Fehler, also da möchte ich dich als Talentberater davor warnen, jetzt es noch ernst zu machen, den Cash-In sozusagen zu machen. Ich habe mich seitdem nicht mehr getraut, eine Partie zu spielen. Die Steine anzufassen. Ich habe mich nicht mehr getraut, weil ich dachte, was soll jetzt passieren? Ja, das ist auch mal, ich finde es immer gut, wie es in jeder Disziplin so gewisse Codes gibt, wo man weiss, die Leute kennen sich aus. Zum Beispiel sagt man beim Schach und an den Weissen Steinen Stefan Tietze. Und nicht so an was? Du wirst sagen, ja die weissen Figuren, ja die schwarzen Figuren. So spreche ich, wie ich spreche. Gemein. Aber wenn du dich auskennst, sagst du an den Weissensteinen Stefan Tietze. Aber dann erkennt man ja in diesem Film über den Underdog, erkennt man ja, das ist ja immer sympathisch, wenn der Underdog sich hinsetzt und weiß nicht genau, wie man die Geflogenheiten sind. Das ist ja auch bei Beth Harmon so, bei Queen's Gambit, die weisst ja auch nicht genau, was es ist. Aber wenn wir die Thailand Open spielen, zusammen mit Greg Gustafsson, dann werde ich auf jeden Fall versuchen, in meinem Beth Harmon-Moment, das hat der Jan auch gesagt, dass wir es hinkriegen, dass ich da als komplettes Niemand kennt mich in der Schachsäne und ich gewinne dann dieses Turnier. Das ist die Idee. Ich finde, man müsste da wirklich so einen Auftritt machen, dass du wirklich so auch einen ganz exzentrischen Stil hast und dass alle enormen Respekt von dir haben. So diese No-Name, niemand kennt ihn, niemand weiss, wer es ist. Man hat da mal was gehört, okay, hat er irgendwie so UFO, weiss ich nicht, was man da kommt, wenn man googelt. Verschwörungstheorie. Aber du auch so extrem exzentrisch irgendwie trägst, so irgendwie so zwei Brotlaibe als Schuhe, irgendwie so ganz, ganz strange. Ja, vor allem ist es ja nicht schwierig, in einer, erstmal tragen auch alle Anzug und wenn ich da schon mit Jonghinghose und Sonnenbrille zum Beispiel auftauchen würde, wäre es ja schon ein Exzentriker. Du nimmst den Stuhl, wenn du dich hinsetzt ans Brett, nimmst den Stuhl, drehst ihn um und machst den Vertretungsländer und alle so, wow, coolest guy ever. Ja, oder irgendwie so einen schönen, irgendwie so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so einen, so irgendwie so ein schön, irgendwie so ein Vape, so ein Vape, so ein gevape Joint. Und dann immer auf die Figuren so, also diese Mebel mehr. Schön mit deinem Bubblegum-Geschmack dann irgendwie dem Gegner ins Gesicht pusten. Wird ja richtig gut. Und dann erst so rausfliegen. Kann ich mit meinen eigenen Steinen spielen und dann setzt du so deine Star-Wars-Figuren drauf auf die Fälle. Oder so Harry Potter Zauberstack, wo die Bauern den Gegner so kaputt machen.
Und dann fliegt die erste Runde raus. Das wird nämlich ja dann auch so passieren. Ja klar, natürlich. Aber der Auftritt bis dahin. Wir müssen es gucken, dass du möglichst spät spielst, damit du einen möglichst imposanten Auftritt machst und die Schachszene dich wahrnimmt. Und ich will, dass du aufs Cover von einem Schachmagazin kommst. Von Chess. Von dem Schachschachmagazin Chess. Von Rochade, das Schachmagazin. Das ist mein Ziel, egal wie du abschneidest, ich will, dass du irgendwann in deiner Wohnung zwei Bilderrahmen hast mit den Covern von zwei Schachmagazinen, wo du auf dem Cover bist. Okay, also die Challenge, wenn wir nächstes Jahr die Talent Open machen. Erklär das mal vielleicht kurz. Das haben wir schon letzte Woche erklärt, glaube ich, vorletzte Woche. Wir können es nochmal erklären. Im Stream mit Jan hatten wir die Idee, weil das das einzige Turnier ist, was Jan noch regelmäßig spielt. Und er ist auch immer noch der amtierende Champion der Thailand Open, weil er wegen Corona jetzt auch viel ausgefallen ist und er war der letzte Gewinner. Und er ist gut mit der Turnierleitung etc. Heißt, wir können, das war dann die Idee, wir begleiten ihn mit einer Kamera und einem kleinen Team von Rocket Beans, fahren wir da hin, Fabian kommt auch noch mit und ich werde auf jeden Fall antreten in dieser B-Gruppe. Kann man da einfach so, ist das so eine Art Open Mic, Open Bishop? Ja, Thailand Open, ich glaube das Open steht für offen. Ach so, okay, danke. Bin mir aber auch jetzt nicht sicher. Ja, ja. Und ich, aber eigentlich möchte ich nicht in dieser B-Runde spielen, ich möchte in der Hauptgruppe spielen, als was ich ja letztendlich auch bin, der Begnaderschaft der Geschichte. Und vor allem hat er das auch in dem Stream gesagt, und ich habe mir das Video nochmal angeschaut, weil ich auch wissen wollte, wie meine Züge kommentiert werden, und Jan sagt, dass der Stefan nie erfahren. Cut zu die ganze Folge rede ich jetzt nur noch darüber. Und er hat das gesagt, er hat das gesagt. Aber dann ist meine Idee, dass ich da mitmache und ja, im Idealfall eine Runde weiterkommen, das wäre das Coolste. Weil ich glaube, da sind auch manche Anfänger dabei vielleicht und so. Ich glaube, du kannst durch die Psychologie viel rausführen. Wie gesagt, Accenture Auftritt, du hast immer einen Dolmetscher bei dir, du darfst nur über einen Spiegel angeschaut werden. Aber der Dolmetscher... Also Herr Tietze verbietet ihn direkt anzusehen, man darf nur über einen Spiegel mit ihm reden. Und er redet auch nur immer... Du hast immer so einen Spiegel dabei und durch den schaust du die Leute an, mit denen du redest. Du schaust Leuten, man darf ihm nie direkt ins Gesicht schauen, das ist unhöflich in seiner Kultur. Und manche sagen, man versteinert dabei, wenn man ihn anrückt, aber das weiss man nicht. Und aus welcher Kultur ist das? Das weiss man nicht. Stellen Sie diese Frage nie wieder. Ja, du bist dann dabei, du bist ein persönlicher Assistent. Ja, aber okay, also die Zielsetzung wäre nämlich jetzt klarer formuliert. Also, Jan Gustafsson gewinnt, das ist das Ziel. Was wir als Gruppe erreichen möchten, ist eigentlich Hauptquest, Jan gewinnt die Thailand Open, ich lande auf dem Schachmagazin Cover, egal wie. Rösselsprung, das Schachmagazin, gibt es wahrscheinlich alle. Wahrscheinlich wirklich. Ich lande irgendwie auf dem Cover, danach, das wäre cool. Kann ja auch so ein Skandälchen sein. Ja klar, klar, die Schachwelt wird vibrieren, also das wird noch über Monate diskutiert werden. Ich finde das gut, einfach mal in so eine komplett fremde Welt einzudäumen und da einfach mal ein bisschen Trubel anzurechnen. Ich hätte ja vielleicht auch eine grosse Schachkarriere vor mir haben können, aber... Ich finde auch gut, wenn Fabian gewinnt. Und trotzdem reden alle mit mir. Genau, du groß im Schachcover einfach so in so eine kleine Fussnote. Winner, Krane. Krani, Krani. Also offensichtlich das grössere Talent und ist so unfassbar gut.
Aber am Ende schreiben Sie über mich. Das wäre doch
ein Geiles. Ja, das finde ich auch gut. Also wir haben eine
Menge Ziele. Ja, wir haben eine Menge Ziele. Es ist ein sehr
stressiger Urlaub, aber hauptsächlich natürlich
auch in Thailand am Strand liegen und schön irgendwie
Coco Cabana. Coco Chanel.
Coco Chanel Schle.
Egal welcher Drink, auch wenn es eine Fanta ist, aus einer Kokosnuss. Ich will eine Fanta in einer Kokosnuss. Fanta in einer Kokosnuss, okay. Das steht mir eklig vor. Aber ich hätte ja tatsächlich auch vielleicht eine große Schachkarriere vor mir haben können, weil ich war im Schachclub tatsächlich als Jugendlich oder als Kind. Im Club richtig. Im Club richtig im Club. Und dann gab es aber ein Ereignis, nachdem ich den Schachklub verlassen habe.
Und dieses Ereignis war, dass ein Kind aus meinem Schachklub die Wetten, dass Kinderwette gemacht hat und gewonnen hat.
Und danach war ich im Schachklub mit jemandem, der im deutschen Fernsehen war, Star, und ich habe mir gesagt, ne, ne.
Und du wolltest damit nichts mit dem? Wenn ich nicht der grösste Name im Raum bin, dann verlasse ich den Raum. So einfach ist das. Und schon damals habe ich gesagt, ne, dann bin ich hier raus. Ich bin nicht die zweite Pfeife hier. Ich mache hier nicht den Bauern. Ich bin raus. Das heisst, du hast das Sprichwort, if you're the smartest one in the room, you're in the wrong room, umbenannt in, if you're not the smartest one in the room leave the room. Genau. Das heisst, du rufst einfach den langweiligeren Raum, damit du da zumindest die Nummer eins bist. Genau. Small fish in a big, ne big fish in a small pond. Ich nehme das ein bisschen als Beleidigung, hätte ich das, habe ich gesagt, aber okay. Ich habe ja schon einige Podcasts abgebrochen, bis ich dich gefunden habe. Ja, aber jetzt, wo ich da begann, als er Schaffspieler der Geschichte bin. Jetzt muss ich auch wieder raus. Vielleicht du warst auch gerade schon mal kurz draußen, aber du hast den nochmal anders überlegt. Schwer ist, wenn du bei Wetten nass bist. Aber der hatte die Wette. Ja, aber gerade fragen wir, hat man was mit Schach zu tun gehabt? Nein. Hat man was mit Schach zu tun gehabt. Der Promi, wir sagen mal Tom Hanks, also Tom Hanks wurde gefragt, er sollte eine Herr Hanks, Herr Hanks, also ich bin Thomas Gottschalk, der Junge aus Jakobs-Neuried wettet, dass er, wenn sie ihm eine Position auf dem Schachbrett... So haben wir das doch nie gemacht und es fällt mir länger nicht, auf Englisch zu hören. Schafbett nennen. Chessboard. Also, we'll also Schachbrett nennen, und er schafft es dann, mit dem Springer, von dieser Position auf jedes andere Feld des Schachbretts, einmal zu springen, aber nur ein einziges Mal. But only one time. Can you repeat this, please? Well, listen, he looks like a bright kid. Also, er sieht aus wie ein scheides Kind. And I know how hard chess can be. Und ich weiss, wie hart schacht er. I've tried it a couple times in my youth, but I wasn't really good at it. My grandpa, he taught it to me and he always crushed me. So I stopped playing. Also habe ich aufgehört zu spielen. I went into acting because that was easier for me. Und deswegen habe why I started playing in the show. Stop laughing! Okay. So, yeah, I think he looks like a bright kid. Yeah, he looks like a bright kid. Yeah, he's in a chess club. And if he doesn't have that, he doesn't have much else, not a world-class acting talent. I think he can do it. And I will choose... Sorry, do I have to choose the position? Muss ich das jetzt wählen? I have to choose the position on the... Yes, you have to. Are you asking me, the translator? Meinten Sie jetzt gerade mich? Meinten Sie mich gerade? Haben Sie jetzt mich als Übersetzer gefragt? Did you ask me as a translator? I hablas espanol. So, sorry, who is talking here? I need to know. I need to know. He's telling me to name him a position on the chessboard.
Or does he tell me, who is he, who am I? Who am I? I am Tom Hanks. I know that because it is written on my Oscar. Alright? Okay, so no doubt about that there. Also, no doubtifel. Nein, nein, Sie müssen schon jetzt dem Jungen eine Position nennen, aufstehen, Schaflade. Irgendeine Position. Ich war vor, die mit dem Satz werde ich. Irgendeine Position, egal welche. Any position, it doesn't matter. Ah, alright, okay, now I got it. Ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. So, okay, so I'm gonna pick a very difficult one. Ich werde eine sehr schwierige nehmen difficult one. It's A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H and one to eight. So I will go for H5. H5. Yeah, that's not, maybe not H5. No, please don't do H5. Alright, okay, then let's say D7. Dann D7. Okay, okay, das funktioniert. Well, it works. Und dann? Moment, ich habe in unserem ganzen Trubel, aber ich kann es vergessen, was die Aufgabe ist. Die Aufgabe ist, Tom Hanks nimmtnt ihn die Position auf dem Schachbrett und da stellst du deinen Springer hin.
Das Pferd.
Du kannst alle Positionen nennen, auf die er springen kann.
Genau. Jetzt muss er aus dem Kopf die Position nennen, auf die der Springer springen kann.
Und er darf jedes Feld nur einmal berühren und muss jedes Feld einmal berühren.
Was?
Er muss übers Feld springen, sodass er jedes Feld einmal berührt. Crazy, okay. Aber er darf keines zweimal berühren. Was? Er muss übers Feld springen, so dass er jedes Feld
einmal berührt. Aber er darf keines zweimal berühren. Ja. Und da hast du gesagt, wenn er das schafft, bin ich raus. Ich habe die Aufgabe nicht mehr verstanden, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Springer läuft, weil er das mit dem Diagonalen, ich habe keine Ahnung. Okay, dann E4, E4, D2, D2, D2, I don't know, F3, F3. Und so ging das weiter und weiter und weiter und dann am Ende tatsächlich schaffte er es auf das letzte Feld. Nein. He did it! You're a great, you're a great kid, you're a great kid, you're a great kid. Und die Musik ist toll. I love the music. Es ist so eine gute Tune, ich mag dance, I like to move my body, I like to wiggle with my arms, to shake my head left to right. It's so great. I love it. Can I walk on the stairs? The big stairs? Let me walk on it. Look at me! Look at me! I'm Tom Hanks! Play the music again, play it again, louder, louder, louder, louder. Ja und so geschah es dann tatsächlich, dass dieser Junge aus meinem Schachklub die Kinderwette gewonnen hat, natürlich der grosse Star war, natürlich der Prominente der gesamten Schule, der gesamten Landkreises. Und da habe ich gesagt, nö, nö, nö. Und was hat er dann mit seinem Skill gemacht, mit seinem ausserordentlichen Skill? Ja, das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ich weiß nicht, was aus dem geworden ist. Das Einzige, was ich von ihm weiss, ist, dass er nicht der talentierteste Spieler der Welt ist. Das weiss ich auch. Das bist du. Der Geschichte. Der Geschichte. Denn da rein inbegriffen ist, dass alle Menschen, die vor mir kamen und die Steine berührt haben. Und technisch gesehen auch die, die nach dir kommen. Aber er sagt nicht der Geschichte bis jetzt, sondern er sagt aller Zeiten, es wird nie wieder ein grösseres Talent geben als dich. Das kleine Wörtchen wahrscheinlich unterschlagen. Und ich weiss auch nicht, ob Ironie, also müsste ich nicht jetzt schon einen Artikel bekommen im Schachmagazin? Im Grunde schon. Im Grunde schon. Ich wäre jedenfalls, ja. Also ich wäre auch bereit, irgendwie so eine Medikamentensucht oder sowas. Halt irgendwie etwas, was mich spannender vielleicht macht. B-Plot? Ja, weil B-Plot, das fehlt mir noch tendenziell. Ja. Ich weiss nicht, ob es reicht, mit Rockerbeams, Fabian Kraner und Funden Will, Jango Sasson nach Thailand zu begleiten. Ich weiß nicht, ob es als B-Plot reicht für eine Netflix-Serie. Aber als angehender Schach-Grossmeister reist du ja viel. Vielleicht kannst du ja nebenbei noch so Drogenkurier sein. Dass du so aus deiner Jugendgeschichte kennst du noch so ein paar Leute, so ein paar Jungs, und da stehst du in deren Schuld, weil die dich mal gerettet haben, weil du mal Scheisse gebaut hast, besoffen und dann haben die dich da aus dem Gefängnis rausgeholt. Jetzt musst du für die Drogen schmucken und die sagst, ey, egal wo du hinfährst, mit deinem ganzen, wie heißt das hier, Mühle, Rommey-Ding da hier, wenn du da hinfährst, was, halt den Mund, wenn ich mit dir rede, wenn du da hinfliegst mit deinem Kinderquatsch da, dann nimmst du mal schön ein Kilo Koks mit, ja?
Steckst dir das da schön bei dir hinten rein oder wo du immer auch, wo es dir gefällt, mir ist mir egal, was du machen willst, ja?
Das klingt sehr gefährlich.
Okay, und dann bringst du das...
Wie du offensichtlich tiefer sprichst, als du eigentlich musst.
Was? Nein, ich rede immer so. Okay, und dann, wenn du da bist hier irgendwo in Thailand oder Peru oder wo dein Quatsch da stattfindet, dann kommt jemand auf dich zu und dann gibst du dem dein
Aber Nein, ich rede immer so. Okay, und dann, wenn du da bist hier irgendwo in Thailand oder Peru oder wo dein Quatsch da stattfindet, dann kommt jemand auf dich zu und dann gibst du dem dein Paket, okay? Aber was ist, wenn ich gerade ein wichtiges Turnierpartietraum habe? Ja, das ist egal, das Paket geht vor. Okay. Alles klar? Ja. Gut, haben wir uns ja verstanden. Hier hast du schon mal zehn Pakete. Warum reden Bösewichte immer so tief und auch authentisch tief? Kommt das daher oder fangen die alle so an und dann entwickelt sich das, dass die Tonlage langsam sich angleicht? Mr. Potter. Mr. Potter. Wie heißt der nochmal? Alan Rickman. Der ist, glaube ich, einer dieser Bösewichte, der immer so ein bisschen nicht so tief spricht. Der spricht ein bisschen... Mr. Potter! Mr. Potter! Ich habe auch gemerkt, wie schlecht ich in Imitationen bin. Manchmal... Ehrlich, also Tom Hanks war spot on. Und ich bin gerade auch mit baldigem Akzent. Mega. Das war auch gut. Ja, da falle ich ja manchmal rein. Würdest du sagen, ich bin der talentierteste Nachwuchsimitator der Geschichte? Also dafür, dass du erst seit zwei Minuten angefangen hast, Imitationen zu machen, bin ich bis zu der talentierteste? Stimmt eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt anfange mit Schach und innerhalb von 30 Sekunden nur ein bisschen gut werde, dann habe ich eine schnellere Geschwindigkeit als du. Das wäre eine bessere Lernkurveve, ja. Steilere Lernkurve. Werbung. Alles ist besser mit Snacks. Egal was man macht, nebenbei einfach sich noch irgendwas schön zwischen die Zähne zu schieben, ist einfach das Beste, was es gibt. Und falls ihr nicht wisst, wo man die besten Snacks der Welt herbekommt, dann haben wir eine kleine Empfehlung für euch, nämlich Koro. Auf korodrogerie.de könnt ihr euch alles bestellen, natürlich auch fantastisch gesunde Snacks wie getrocknete Früchte, Kokoschips, Bananenchips, verschiedene Arten von getrockneten Chips, getrocknete Tomaten, auch herzhafte Snacks, Chips, Süsskartoffelchips. Ich komme gar nicht mehr raus aus dem Schwärmen. Ich hole dich kurz raus, denn Koro ist die Nummer eins für Snacks, für Nüsschen, für Superfoods, für alles andere. Und das Beste ist, mit dem Code UFO bekommt ihr 5% Rabatt auf alle Artikel. Also benutzt den Code UFO, das schreibt man U-F-O, auf korodrogerie.de, könnt ihr das eingeben und stürmt mal ein bisschen darum. Ich habe so ganz viele tolle Sachen gefunden, die werde ich mir alles schön in meinen Bauch stecken. Es gibt richtig viele tolle Sachen, getrocknete Himbeeren, getrocknete Erdbeeren, man kann sich das alles reinschieben. Das ist ja ökologisch auch, mit grossen Verpackungen. Ökologisch, gesund und es gibt natürlich auch relativ wenig Verpackungen, weil die in ziemlich grossen Packungen angeboten werden. Ich schlafe mittlerweile auf so einem Kissen ausgetrockneten Himbeeren. Ich schlafe in so einem Kissen drin. Ist auch auf jeden Fall grossartig und macht das mal, schaut mal vorbei auf korodrogerie.de, da ist wirklich für jeden was dabei. Und ja, bestellt und lasst es euch schmecken. Werbung. Hast du jetzt auch Lust, das anzufangen? Nee. Einfach um mich auszustechen?
Nee, ich habe das tatsächlich gerne geguckt.
Alte Taktik, jetzt ist das Thema für dich tot.
Ja genau, also wenn es nicht ganz leicht ist, der Beste zu werden, würde ich es nicht machen.
Okay.
Und deswegen... Also leise Ball wieder.
Dann hänge ich zurück zu leise Ball, zurück in meine Halle, die ich mir angemietet habe.
Ich habe immer Donnerstag, 19 bis 20 Uhr.
Da wollte ich nochmal drüber reden, weil das läuft über unser gemeinschaftliches Konzept.
Genau, weil wir zusammen gesagt haben, wir sind ein Team. Ja, aber dass du jetzt eine Halle gemietet hast, da wollte ich nochmal mit dir drüber reden. Komisch, weil ich es bislang noch nicht angesprochen habe, jetzt wo ich drüber nachdenke, weil du hast eine Halle angemietet. Genau, ich habe immer eine Stunde verwochen. Ja, und der Verein, der da drin trainiert, die machen Touren und so, rhythmische Sportgymnastik. Ja, die müssen leider raus. Warum? Ich hochleide die ganze Halle, weil es geht um Lautstärke. Wie lange? H Stunde, bis dann aufbaut zwei Stunden, eine Stunde Training und dann eine Stunde abbau. Du hast die ganze Halle gemietet. Ja, ja, ja. Alle Vereine rausgeschmissen. Ja, ja. Ne, weil Schallwellen bleiben halt auch noch eine Weile im Raum, wenn du halt so in dem Raum, die bouncen ja so zwischen den Wänden hin und her, teilweise stundenlang. Die Schule, die daneben ist, die muss jetzt auf eine andere Halle ausweichen. Ja, die müssen ewig lang, die müssen durch so eine Sumpflandschaft gehen, wenn ja schon fünf Kinder gestorben. Aber guck mal, das ist jetzt der Teil im Film, wo alle sagen, nein, das lohnt sich nicht, du schaffst es nicht, aber wir alle wissen, wie der Film ausgeht. Abspannen. Ja. Und darauf will ich hin. Aufstehen und Parkplatz finden. Wo ist mein Auto? Oh, ich hab noch Popcorn im Ausschnitt. So was. Ja. So endet der Film. Und da will ich hin. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Aber kann ja vielleicht eine kleinere Halle sein. Du willst nicht einer von denen sein, die im Film gesagt haben, du schaffst es eh nicht, du schaffst es eh nicht. Du willst einer von denen sein, die das Schild hochgehoben haben für den Jemel, aber leise bitte. Kein Styropor. Das finde ich ja immer noch nicht schlecht. Ich finde es ja, ich mache meine Spääße, meine Witzchen und meine Juckse, aber eigentlich ist es immer noch eine mega Idee. Zumal das Publikum ja auch massgeblich mit einem Erfolg beteiligt ist, weil die wollen die natürlich supporten, aber am ehesten supporten sich ja durch Abwesenheit, weil Abwesenheit ist wahnsinnig leise. Das Problem ist halt, du kannst halt leider für deine Gegner einfach reinschreien und dann muss man, silence please, silence please. Und deswegen dauern Turniere auch manchmal einfach zwei Jahre. Weil immer wieder, silence please. Und dann muss man einfach immer wieder machen. Warum ist eine Möwe hier drin? Hier in Hamburg gibt es, wir sind ja in Hamburg heute mal, weil ich eine Woche in Hamburg bin, hier gibt es Möwen. In Köln sieht man keine Möwen. Da habe ich mich gefreut. Die sind riesig, teilweise sind die richtig groß, sind groß wie ein Hund. Die sind wirklich fucking groß. Hundsgrosse Möwen. Richtig hoch. Also hoch und breit und flügelstark. Also die schwingen, die blasen alles weg, wenn die da aufsteigen. Das ist echt krass. Wir haben es auch geschafft, mit jahrzehntelanger Domestitation, haben wir es doch geschafft, Hunde klein, süss zu züchten, lieb zu züchten.
Warum haben wir es nicht geschafft, Vögel zu so grossen Vögeln zu züchten, dass man
darauf reiten kann? Ja, Vögel werden ja schnell gezüchtet. Also gerade Tauben werden
auf Schnelligkeit gezüchtet. Ja, es gibt nämlich den Taubensport. Und die Idee ist, die Taubenhalter treffen sich an einem Punkt.
Das wäre doch was für dich.
Du bist der begnadete Taubensportler.
Taubensportler, es ist tatsächlich ein Sport.
Es gibt Taubende, die ihre Tauben trainieren.
Und zwar fährt man zusammen irgendwie an den Punkt.
Okay, das ist die generischste Beschreibung von etwas.
Wir fallen alle an den Punkt, um dann zu gewinnen. Nee, also die Tauben kommen alle an einen Punkt und werden da irgendwie so gecheckpointet. So, jetzt ist hier Checkpoint. Und dann nehmen die Tauben und fahren die alle hundert Kilometer weit weg. Aber alle in
einem Bus.
Alle Tauben in einem Bus, alle
Menschen im zweiten Bus. Wer sitzt hinten?
Da fängt es doch schon an. Ja, das ist
schwierig, aber das kriegt man nicht mit.
Die sind ja halt, es ist auch demütig
für Tauben die.
Für einen Omnibus. Aber sind die
in kleinen Käfigen im Omnibus? Nein, die sitzen
auf den Sitzen, jeder auf einem. Und dann fährst du im Bus einen Bus Menschen, einen Bus Tauben, dann fährst du irgendwo anders hin. Zwei Busse. Zwei Busse, gut. Fährst du irgendwo anders hin. Und dann sagt man, drei, zwei, eins, los! Und dann werden alle Tauben freigelassen und die sind so schlau, dass die automatisch zu ihrem Checkpunkt zurückfliegen. Wie wird der Checkpunkt den eingetrichtert? Die sagen jetzt, hier ist der Checkpunkt. Checkpunkt! Ja, die haben dann so ein Code-Wort. Und dann müssen die aber die Besitzer ganz schnell, schneller als die Vögel bestenfalls, zurückfahren zum Checkpunkt. Und dann guckt man, wessen Vogel kommt als erstes an, wer ist der schnellste. Und dann die Zeile, die dann im Wikipedia-Eintrag danach kam, hat mich am meisten fasziniert. Denn die Gewinnertaube kriegt einen Preis und alle anderen Tauben werden gegessen. Ah ja, okay. Bis dahin sehr niedlicher Sport, aber da wirklich einfach fucking barbarisch, der Gewinner da fleben alle anderen, alle anderen werden gegessen. Die Tauben hätten es werden können, in dem Moment, wo alle Besitzer angefangen haben zu weinen, als sie die Logen schickt haben, schon bei der Turnieranmeldung angefangen haben zu weinen, da hätten sie es merken können. Das heißt, die Tauben fliegen, warum fliegen die nicht weg? Das ist so dämlich, dass die Tauben... Ja, die müssen ja zum Checkpunkt fliegen. Als dritte Taube, du siehst es ja, zwei sind vor mir, ich habe keine Chance mehr. Die zweite landet in der Fritteuse, die dritte darf dann nicht mehr landen, wenn sie das schon gesehen hat. Ja, wenn die sieht, oh fuck, fuck, fuck. Ja, ja, ja. Oh, da wird ein Salat angerührt, da wird ein bisschen was beilagen. Klassischer Taubensalat. Schwierig, aber ja, es gibt, glaube ich, man kann alles als Sport machen. Irgendwie so ein spezielles Taubendelikatessenessen, wo du so ein... Wie Eier? So ein... Nee, du isst Tauben, die werden dann so geröstet und dann isst du die, beist du den Kopf so ab. Ah ja, stimmt. Du hast so ein Tuch über dem Kopf. Das ist genau, weil es so ekelhaft aussieht, wenn man den Kopf abbeisst. Genau, aber auch damit das ganze, der ganze Geruch und das ganze Aroma in dir bleibt und noch lange noch erhalten bleibt, hast du so ein feuchtes Tuch oder sowas über dem Kopf. Ganz weird. Auch verboten. In irgendeiner Serie machen die das, essen die das auch so. Ich glaube, es ist Succession? Weiß ich nicht. Das kann so gut sein, ja. Also auf jeden Fall auch weird. Vielleicht essen die das dann genau so. Das wäre auf jeden Fall hochreich seltsam. Die Welt der Delikatessen, auch spannend, ne? Also diese ganzen... Und warum wird das dann einfach, warum werden die getötet? Kein, muss ja was essen. Auch weil die so schlecht waren, ne, vielleicht. Und sie überleben dann auch nur die schnellsten Tauben. Ja, ich weiß nicht, tatsächlich sind ja alle Stadttauben, waren mal ursprünglich so Taubenschlagtauben. Die haben überlebt. Die haben überlebt und haben jetzt ihr eigenes Ding gemacht. Es sind immer so Exiltauben, die aus diesem furchtbaren Sport ausgebrochen sind, um ihr Leben in der Stadt zu schaffen. Die, die geflohen sind. Ja. Sie fressen jetzt Pommes. Aber ich verstehe trotzdem nicht, warum man es nicht grösser züchtet. Weil Vögel grösser züchten wäre einfach eine mega Idee. Ja, oder noch kleiner. Vielleicht versuchen die Hälfte sie grösser zu züchten und die andere Hälfte kleiner und dann paaren die sich ab immer wieder und die sagen, nein, jetzt habt ihr genau die Mitte wieder. Jetzt habt ihr wieder genau die Mitte. Jetzt haben wir den mittelmässigsten Vogel aller Zeiten gezüchtet. Warum und zu welchem Preis? Ja, ja. Ich habe ja auch immer noch die Idee, dass man so Graffen ganz klein züchtet, dass die so auf dem Tisch rumlaufen, so kleine Pferdchen, die sind so fünf Zentimeter hoch und laufen die so rum. Kann ich mir aber eh vorstellen, weil Hunde werden auch bewusst klein gezüchtet, vielleicht wird dann auch alles kleiner so, dann passt sich alles an. Ich würde Vögel eher gross züchten, dass man darauf reiten kann irgendwann. Ja, genau. Das war die Ausgangsfrage. Das wäre schon... Das muss ich so als deine Idee jetzt hier darstellen. Aber denkst du da an einen Sattel oder denkst du daran, dass der Mensch an den Krallen unten hängt oder obendrauf sitzt? Ich denke vollbläum an Avatar, wo ich mir, wo ich mit weiß ich nicht, was der Mensch die Körper reinsteckt. Aber wo willst du denn da sitzen, weil du kannst ja nicht die Beine wie bei einem Pferd rechts und links baumeln lassen. Doch. Nie, Solgerson sitzt, aber auf einer Gans, die hat ja einen ganz langen Hals. Auf einer Gans, ja. Ja. gut, aber die Gans, der würde hier so ein Airbus, wenn du die gross züchtest, oder? Das wäre geil. Ey, die Gans wäre geil. Dann hast du die zwischen den Beinen, dann kannst du dich rechts und links raus den Baumel lassen und dann fliegt die Gans da vorne. Ich denke immer daran eher, dass der Mensch, der Passagier, an den Krallen unten hängt, dass der so gepackt wird, so wie Frodo und Sam. Spoiler, von den Adlern am Ende, dass sie dann so weggeflogen werden. Was? Die werden weggeflogen? Ich habe mir tatsächlich jetzt letztens die Zeichentrickverfilmung von Herr der Ringe angeschaut. An alle Herr der Ringe-Fans da draußen, mach das mal. Das ist, also falls ihr die Peter-Jackson-Trilogie schon oft gesehen habt, 1978 wurde Herr der Ringe verfilmt als Zeichentrickfilm. Und das ist ein ganz merkwürdiger Film. Gleiche Story? Ja, also basiert natürlich auf den Büchern. Und es sollte anscheinend mehrere Filme geben, weil der erste Film endet nach Helms Klamm, der Schlacht von Helms Klamm. Also ungefähr da, wo der zweite Peter-Jackson-Film endet, endet der Film. Also ganz merkwürdiges Ende auch. Und das ist so ganz merkwürdig, weil wenn du halt die Peter-Jackson-Trilogie kennst und wieder die Figuren gezeichnet, also die Charakterzüge sind auch, da ist manches ganz merkwürdig in dem Film. Und auch irgendwie Gandalf ist irgendwie ein Arschloch, Sam ist total dumm. Also ganz, ganz merkwürdig, ganz krude. Und schaut euch das wirklich mal an. Und es ist vor allem teilweise auch ganz merkwürdig gefilmt, weil manche Sachen sind so real. Ganz ein bisschen Arschloch. Ja, mega geil. Ja, richtig gut. Der ist richtig unsympathisch. Ist alles gleich, aber ganz ein bisschen Arschloch. Die Mimik ist auch ganz merkwürdig von den Leuten. Man hat, also obwohl es ein Zeichentrickfilm ist, hat man das Gefühl, die schneiden immer zu spät weg.
Ab und zu ist ein Mikrofon im Bild. Aber genau dieses Gefühl hat es manchmal. Dann passiert irgendwas und Frodo reagiert mit der Mimik und dann entspannt er sich wieder so. Und dann denkt man, schneid doch davor weg. Nee, du musst nicht schneiden, du kannst es zeichnen. Das ist so, ihr könnt es einfach verändern. Aber esürdig. Und vor allem, das sind teilweise reale Aufnahmen, die dann, glaube ich, überzeichnet wurden.
Also das sind schon Zeichentricks, aber das sieht man, merkt genau, dass das echte Menschen waren, die abgefilmt wurden.
Es ist teilweise ganze wirre Farben, die flackern.
Also schau es dir an, es ist wirklich ein Erlebnis.
Das können wir ausgiebig besprechen in unserer Folge Antenne Auenland. Antenne Auenland, falls die Community sich dazu herablässt, mal ihre Stimme zu Antenne Auenland zu geben. Antenne Azkaban hat ja damals gewonnen im grossen Rennen, Antenne Auenland, Antenne Abo. Mit so viel Abstand, dass wir noch nichts anderes jemals Eingriff mal genommen haben. Nee, können wir nicht machen. Und macht das auf jeden Fall, schaut euch den Hobbit an, kann man auf jeden Fall finden im Internet und ist auf jeden Fall ein grossartiges Erlebnis, weil es ganz merkwürdig ist.
Und es ist eine Geschichte, die man so gut kennt und die nochmal aus einer anderen Perspektive zu erzählen.
Man denkt sich, ist es nur so strange, weil man die andere Interpretation kennt oder wäre es auch so strange, wenn man nur das kennen würde?
Es klingt schon strange. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, aber sowas wie Gandalf ist ein Arschloch, er macht schon auch Sinn.
Also der ist ja auch nicht, der ist ja auch ein Arschloch, strenges Arschloch.
Ja, manche Sachen waren ja im Buch auch anders. Ich kann mir vorstellen, wie Meri und Pippen, wenn man gerne auf den Raum verlässt, ab und zu sagen, Arschloch. Das ist eigentlich veranlagt. Man sieht uns jetzt ein altertümliches Sprachrat, aber ganz plötzlich... Wichser. Ja, aber macht das auf jeden Fall, ist ein schöner Nachmittag. Kann man sich mal geben, ist ein schöner Nachmittag. Es kommt immer auf den Blickwinkel an. Bei Marion Pippin war Gander Fähig einfach ein riesen Arschloch. Ja, das stimmt schon. Der war superoperlehrerhaft und so. Es gibt so eine Szene, wo er sich umdreht und weg von Sam und dann dreht er sich nochmal zusammen und will ihn so erschrecken. Und Sam zog zusammen und er geht dann nur weg. Was ist das für ein Move? Einfach nochmal Sam erschrocken so und er so und dann wieder einfach weg und er so, was war das denn? Bei einem Zeichentrickfilm, wo du einfach sagst, nee, lass uns das noch hinzufügen, dass Sam nochmal erschrickt. Null Plotreleranz, nimmt das Messer, sticht Sam, dreimal in den Bauch und rennt weg. Es ist ganz merkwürdig. Ja, freu ich mich drauf, Das ist ein guter Tipp. Es ist auf jeden Fall cool, auch ein paar Entscheidungen anders. Zum Beispiel Arwen taucht ja null im Buch auf. Null, überhaupt nicht, spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Arwen? Arwen. Und für den Film dachte man, ja, so ein Love Interest wäre schon gut und natürlich auch irgendwie so eine Liebesgeschichte zu erzählen. Und dann hat man Arwen eingebaut, aber halt im Buch findet es nicht statt und in dem Film halt auch gar nicht. Also auch so so Frodo wird ja dann so gefunden von Arwen und die bringt ihn nach Bruchtal. Stimmt alles nicht? Wie wird er sonst gefunden? Im Buch ist es Glorfindel, eine Figur, die nirgendwo auftaucht. Und ich finde es geil, dass sowohl Peter Jackson als auch die Zeichenverfilmung sich beide einig waren, dass nicht Glorfindel ihn finden sollte. Glorfindel ist irgend so ein uralter Elbenkrieger, der ultrakrass ist, der irgendwie mit Elrond damals gekämpft hat und der ist ultrakrass, aber der taucht halt nur dafür einmal auf, ist ein uralter Held, aber der taucht nur einmal auf, findet Foto, bringt nach Bruchteiners dann weg. Wohin, fragt man sich, wohin deswegen? Weiss man nicht, weiss man nicht. Und im Film ist es ja Arwen und tatsächlich in der Zeichentrickverfilmung, auch die haben gesagt, nee, lass den mal raus, da ist es Legolas.
Oh ja, das macht Sinn.
Das macht total Sinn.
Das ist cool.
Macht total Sinn.
Aber Arwen auch cool.
Ja, ja klar, wenn du die Figur Arwen interpielen willst.
Also auf jeden Fall spannend, schaut es euch an.
Und schade, es gibt tatsächlich keinen zweiten Teil.
Also diese Interpretation endet nach der Schlacht von Helms Klamm.
Vielleicht gibt es da nochmal ein Crowdfunding-Projekt oder so.
Geil, dass er den Ring genommen hat und runtergeschluckt hat.
Was macht ihr jetzt? Was macht ihr jetzt? Oh, Gandalf. Oder Gandalf den Ring nimmt, der einfach die Welt regiert. Auch grauenhaft. Da habe ich auch noch ein bisschen reingelesen in diese Lore. Das ist schon auch interessant. Gandalf ist ja diese weirde, Zauberkultur, von der es so viel gibt. Ist irgendwie seltsam. Da gibt es ja noch andere. Radagast, Saruman, er und... Und dann noch einen blauen. Ja, so einen anderen. Weissen, blauen, braun und grauen. Und es muss immer einen Weissen geben. Und wo Saruman nicht mehr der Weisse ist, wird er dann der Weisse. Ja, das weiss ich nicht. Was mit Saruman passiert, wenn er der neue Weisse wird? Nee, Saruman, der ist ja nur der Weisse geworden, weil Saruman nicht mehr seine Pflicht als Weisser Magier erfüllt. Ja. Die Frage ist aber dann, wenn er seinen Grauen Posten vernachlässigt, wenn er der Weisse wäre. Wer ist denn der Graue? Mary. Ich will's machen. Mary. Ich will's machen. Ach gut, okay. Bitte, Gott. Mary, Mary. Mary, was ist der Lieblingscharakter von Herr der Ringe? Ach, schwierig, ist schon ein Sam, oder? Ich mag aber auch, ich mag auch Eo mehr, ich mag auch Eowin, ich mag diese ganzen Rohrhandleute. Du magst Eo einfach als Sachsenklären. Ich mag Eo, Eo, ich mag es einfach. Fahrer mir fand ich auch immer cool, wegen Fahrer mir habe ich mir die Haare immer lang wachsen lassen und sah aus wie ein kompletter Vollidiot, lange Zeit meines Lebens. Aber das danke ich ihm trotzdem noch, das hat mich stärker gemacht, glaube ich. Diese Jahre der Demütigung, glaube ich, haben mich letzten Endes stärker gemacht, von daher danke Fahrer mir. Das weiß ich immer, nicht immer die große Frage, was macht einen stärker, Niederlagen, Siege, Demütigungen, ich weiß es nicht. Du musst es wissen, du hast alles richtig gemacht. Du bist der beste Schachspieler aller Zeiten, dieser und aller kommenden Zeiten, aller Zeiten. Das ist schon eine Einschätzung, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Ich freue mich sehr drüber. Ich muss nochmal genau ergründen, was da genau schiefgegangen ist, wie das Bild entstehen konnte. Ich glaube aber auf jeden Fall dran. Und du hast nichts dagegen, so gelobt zu werden, obwohl du nicht so viel dafür gearbeitet hast. Weil eigentlich will man ja eher talentiert sein, als hart arbeiten. Das Zitat war ja auch, ich bin der begnadetste Schachtwil der Geschichte. Ja, was heißt begnadet genau? Ja, lass uns das nur nachschlagen. Ich glaube, es ist nämlich talentiert. Na, begnadet? Ich glaube ja auch an sowas wie talentlich. Habe ich aber schon auch mal, ach, tausendmal. Ja, aber jetzt wirst du vielleicht, jetzt ist das vielleicht jetzt die die Charaktereintegnung, die du durchmachen musst. Du hast nie an Talent geglaubt, jetzt plötzlich merkst du, Moment, ich bin selber talentiert. Ich bin fucking talentiert im scheiss Schachspielen. Mega. Ich gebe mal einen begabt Stefan Tietze. Wenn jetzt irgendwie chess.com über mich schreibt. Wer ist das? Damengambit, das Magazin. Begabt. Er hat gegoogelt, Begabt, Definition Deutsch. Es gibt einen Film, der heißt begabt, mit besonderen Anlagen, Komma Fähigkeiten ausgestattet.
Mit besonderen Fähigkeiten ausgestattet.
Hier ist eine Frage, wann ist man begabt?
Von einer Hochbegabung spricht man im Rahmen eines Intelligenztests, wenn er über 130,
Intelligenztest über 130 bist du hochbegabt, du bist allerdings lediglich begabt, nicht hochbegabt. Also möchte ich hier auch nochmal anmerken. Wenn ich der begabteste Schachtel der Geschichte bin, dann bin ich hier wahrscheinlich hochbegabt, du bist allerdings lediglich begabt, nicht hochbegabt, also möchte ich hier auch nochmal anmählen. Wenn ich der begabteste Schachwähler in der Geschichte bin, dann bin ich wahrscheinlich hochbegabt. Ich weiss es nicht. Aber ich habe mich sehr gefreut, ich muss noch mal, wie gesagt, ergründen, was genau passiert ist jetzt. Schaut es euch an, ist ein tolles Video, macht Spaß. Das Video ist irregeil. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Schach, ich habe es trotzdem gerne gesehen. Es ist mega, was hier schachmässig gerade passiert, allein bei Rocket Beans, ey, irre, es macht so viel Spaß. Ja, schaut mal vorbei, bei Jan Gustav von der sowieso, der werde ich auch demnächst noch ein paar Mal im Stream auftauchen. Gegen Eddie wollte ich auch spielen, den grossartigen Etienne Gade, jetzt mit meinem neu ausgestatteten Lob ein bisschen albern. Also erwarte ich jetzt auch, dass er nochmal ein bisschen drauflegt. Ich bleibe dran, ey, Und vielleicht gewinne ich einfach jetzt mal ein Turnier. Ich habe zumindest überlegt, in so einem Verein beizutreten. Es gibt ja immer wieder so die Geschichte, dass zum Beispiel, dass das Leute, es gibt ja Leute mit Verantwortung. Politiker, Militär, Offiziere, die haben wirklich was zu sagen. Und es gibt ja immer wieder den Fall, dass die Leute heranziehen als Berater, die unkonventionell sind.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel wurde, glaube ich, mal Jerry Bruckheimer gefragt, was er glaubt, was die nächste Naturkatastrophe ist, weil der immer Filme über Naturkatastrophen macht und dann so gefragt wurde, hey, worauf sollen wir uns vorbereiten? Sandsturm, Eis, Tundra, Mr. Bruckheimer, can you tell us please, should we buy like Kälte, Coldwater or Hotwater? Ich glaube, Asteroiden vielleicht. Ja, okay, also dann, wir brauchen ganz viele grosse Netze, über alle grossen Städte spannen wir grosse Netze. Schreibt mal auf, baut das mal. Und das finde ich eigentlich immer ganz spannend, wenn solche Leute rangezogen werden, die irgendwie beraten. Ich glaube, es gab auch mal irgendeinen Schachspieler, der in irgendeinem Krieg oder in irgendeinem Kalten Krieg, glaube ich, irgendwie sowas, der rangezogen wurde als Strategieberatung für Militärs, weil die meinten, ja, der ist doch schlau, vielleicht weiss der weiter, wir haben keine Ahnung. Und dann sollte der was sagen. Ich weiss, dass man jetzt früher nach G7 ist, aber ich keine Ahnung. Ja, nehmt mal irgendwie einen Bischof und der soll so diagonal durch die gegnerischen Reihen so durchflitten. Und alle weg, okay, danke, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben. Pass auf, die Bauern, unterschätätzt mir nicht die Bauern. Man unterschätzt sie, die sind klein, aber die können auch manchmal ein Spiel werden. Okay, und die haben die interpretiert und dann Krieg gewonnen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie sie den Krieg gewonnen haben. Aber was ich nur sagen will, ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, nicht wundern, falls bei dir bald das Handy klingelt und eine unbekannte Nummer ist, geh gern mal ran, weil es könnte natürlich sein, dass da irgendwie... Der war ja der BND, der mich fragt, ob ich irgendwie diesen Enigma entschlüsseln kann.
Genau, sowas in der Richtung.
Also nur, dass du nicht da den Anruf verpasst, der vielleicht ein Leben hat. Ich habe jetzt eh so einen krassen Höhenflug, ich würde wahrscheinlich auch einfach sofort zusagen.
Ja, klar.
Egal, ob ich dafür geeignet bin oder nicht.
Ja.
Das ist gerade so mein Punkt.
Also egal, was jetzt passiert, ich bin geneigt, diese Türschwelle zu überqueren.
Jetzt müsste man es eigentlich ausnutzen, dass du ein hohes Selbstbewusstsein hast,
dass man dich irgendwie zu so einer fadenscheinigen Anlagestrategie oder sowas verführt.
Was ist das? geneigt, diese Türschwelle zu überqueren. Jetzt müsste man es eigentlich ausnutzen, dass du ein hohes Selbstbewusstsein hast, dass man dich irgendwie zu so einer fadenscheinigen Anlagestrategie oder sowas verführt. Man sagt so, Herr Tietze, wir haben gehört, Sie sind begabt. Wir haben da einen Hedgefonds, der ist nur für begabene Menschen. Wo soll ich unterschreiben? Ich bin ja wirklich sehr anfällig für sowas. Mir kann nichts passieren. Jetzt mehr. Ich weiss nicht. nicht, ich finde es sehr... So ein bisschen auf das Mikrofon aufpassen. Entschuldigung, was? Ich finde es sehr lustig einfach. Ja, aber dass du ruhig da reinsprichst. Ja, okay. Ich mache es wahrscheinlich besser. Ich glaube auch, dass ich eher verstehe, wie Mikrofone funktionieren als du. Warum? Weil du so begabt bist? Weil ich so begabt bin. Weil du endete begabt sind Menschen. Nein, weil ich ein guter Schachspieler bin. Weil wir sind clever. Wir werden eingesetzt, um Kriege zu gewinnen. Ja, Schallwellen sind ja auch wie so Läufer eigentlich, die so durch die Gegend abdotzen, fegen. Ja, ich hatte damals ein Schachspiel mit Star Wars Figuren. Und das hat eine Weile gedauert zu entschlüsseln, was was ist. Ja, das während dem spiel häufiger vergessen ja und meinte dann so der turm darf sich nicht so bewegen das ist ein läufer und so wurden die meisten spiele verloren mit diesem und es war Es waren dann einmal so die Bösen gegen die Guten. Geil war aufgeben. Schön die X-Wings waren die Bauer. Ja. Luke Skywalker war der Läufer. Der eine Läufer? Ja. Und was war Turm? Turm war einmal diese roten Imperial Guards, die ultra cool waren. Ja. Aber niemand wusste genau, was das ist, das waren die Türme, und dann auf der guten Seite, glaube ich, war es... Wie verwirrend ist das schon? Ultra verwirrend, ich glaube, Leia war die Dame und Obi-Wan war der König, Luke war der Läufer, aber auch alle Obi-Wan, König, Leia, Dame, ist so weirer, das ist merkwürdig. Aber das war echt ganz, ganz strange. Und ich habe so oft das vergessen. Und ich habe mit meinen Freunden Schach gespielt, aber wir haben es immer nicht gehabt. So erbärmlich. Ich habe einen Schachcomputer gehabt damals, der hat genau gecheckt, wo, das war so ein magnetisches Ding, und er hat genau gecheckt, wo die Figuren gerade sind, und er hat angezeigt. Und ich habe ihn vor allem auf dem Flohmarkt gekauft, weil ich dachte, ah geil, magnetisch, der zieht dann die Figuren. Aber nee, der zeigt dann nur an, wo er was hinhaben will. Ich hatte irgendwann mal einen Reiseschacht, aber irgendwie wurde das falsch geliefert oder war das fehlerhaft. Und dann hat er... Ich selbst verreist. Und dann hatte ich einen Läufer zu wenig, aber ein Bauern zu viel. Und dann haben wir immer ein Bauern. Da könnte ein Bauer immer Läufer sein, aber man hat vergessen, welcher. Und dann haben wir ein Bauern angemalt, dann haben wir gesagt, ja der angemalte Bauer ist ein Läufer, aber haben das natürlich im Laufe des Spiels immer wieder vergessen, sodass im Laufe des Spiels wir immer wieder denselben Fehler gemacht haben, dass wir einen Bauern immer wieder... Die Zuschauer denken, das wäre alles okay. Macht ja nichts. Ja, das Kabel jetzt einfach in den Laptop stehen. Immer wieder vergessen haben. Guck mal, das ist so souverän moderiert, dass man fast dem ist, wenn nichts passiert. Und eigentlich wurde letzten Endes jedes einzelne Spiel dadurch entschieden, dass wir immer vergessen haben, dass Einbauer tatsächlich ein Läufer ist. Okay, die gleiche Geschichte, die du gerade, ich war mal so ehrlich, erzählt. Also, ich bin wahnsinnig hyped, ich freue mich wahnsinnig über das, guckt mal rein, fangt auch mal an Schach zu spielen. Oder nicht. Ja, oder nicht. Oder lassen wir alle etwas finden, worin wir die begnadetsten Menschen der Geschichte sind. Ja. Aber Schach ist, glaube ich, schon eine der cooleren Sachen, um darin begabt zu sein. Wenn du jetzt sehr begabt, dass du Mühlespieler gewesen wärst oder so. Das ist auch so albern. Ich finde es ja so krass, weil ich finde es zum Beispiel so die Fussballleute und bei uns in der Schule hingen die Fussballleute schon auch mit den Handballleuten rum. Also da hat man gesagt, okay, das ist nicht dasselbe, aber wir sind schon von einem ähnlichen Holz gestrickt. Wir schiessen, wir bewegen runde Bälle in Tore, Tornetze. Genau, das lieben wir. Und die Basketballer so, ja wir auch, wir bewegen auch streng genommen runde Gegenstände in Netze. Und die Fussballhandballer so, okay, okay, okay. Diese ganze von oben Sache ist uns suspekt, aber okay, okay. Und genauso wie der Go-Club auch mit dem Schach-Club. Die haben sich auch verstanden. Und dann die Billard-Spieler so, wir bewegen auch runde Gegenstände in Netze. Die sind alle so, Netze, ja, da hängen manchmal auch so net. Es ist eine Tasche, ja, aber bei manchen Tischausführungen... So bei den meisten, die man so kennt, so von Gran Canaria, All-Inclusive oder diese Billardtische, da landen die dann auf so Rohrbahnen. Genau, die rollen ja dann wieder runter in dieses Fach. Da muss man wieder zwei Euro reinstellen. Das ist ein Fach, ein fachähnlicheres Ziel. Ja. Ihr seid nicht dabei. Aber die haben alle die Köse. Die sind einfach richtig cool. Wie so ein Schwert haben die ihre Köse daran. Ja, dann machen die den Joker, die durchbrechen das dann und dann haben die... Ja, habe ich nie verstanden, die Szene. Nein, Casting. Nie verstanden. Make it quick. Die sollen sich umbringen, oder was, gegenseitig? Hast du die Sprache nicht verstanden, oder? Make it quick, was soll das bedeuten? Nee, die sollen sich umbringen, ja. Die hätten nur Platz für einen. Ex... äh, was sag ich nochmal? Pension. Tryouts. Aggressive Expansion. We're having tryouts. Ja, die hätten nur Platz für eine Ex-Pension.
Tryouts.
Aggressive Expansion.
We're having Tryouts.
Ja, Castings.
Ich glaube, du bist doch deutschleutig.
Offensichtlich, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiss nicht, warum das einfällt. Ja, Eichsledger muss man auf Deutsch sehen.
Das will man nicht verpassen, Eichsledger auf Deutsch.
Ja, der ist dafür gestorben, für die Rolle auf Englisch, auf Deutsch.
Der hat, der gab es nur noch einen Platz bei ihm im Team.
Und deswegen, es waren aber zwei Bewerber, zu viele Bewerber auf einem Platz.
Und die sollen mit dem Kölhen sich gegen sich umbringen und der gewinnt. Aber ist das denn so eine grosse Hilfe, so ein Köhen? Er hätte noch durchbrochen mit seinem Knie und dann ist es spitz hinten. Ach so, wie Hector bei Troja. Genau, wie Hector bei Troja. Aber auch überall flohen die nur mal eine andere Referenz. Du musst immer noch mal Troja. Wenn du du das erklären willst, dann musst du dich immer auf Troja beziehen, dann komme ich immer mit.
Aber wenn du es nicht machst, tut es immer schwer. Immer wenn die immer so Photonen, aha.
Ja, das ist wie bei Troja.
Ach so, okay.
Wenn die ganzen Fische, äh, die ganzen Schiffe auf dem Ozean sind.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich's. Und die stossen sich ab mit den Rudern so ein bisschen.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie wir Photonen und so, die sich gleich.
Ja, ist schon ganz cool eigentlich. Schwierig mit Photonen zu sprechen neuerdings. Warum sind die so schnell, Photonen? Die sind schnell, richtig schnell. Die sind so schnell wie der Speer, der auf Achilles geworfen wird. Ja, genau, von Hector und dann fliegt er da hin. Ja, mir gehen auch ehrlich gesagt die Szenen aus langsam. Findest du das einen guten Film wirklich? Troja. Ach ja, ich verwechsel ihn immer mit Alexander und dann komme ich durcheinander. Und dann bin ich verwirrt, dann muss ich mich erstmal hinsetzen. Du musst dich erstmal hinsetzen und ich bin er aufsteig. Dann bräuchte ich so ein kaltes Paket auf dem Kopf. Man sieht dich häufig irgendwo in der stabilen Seitenlage. Stöhnend ausatmen. Und dann brauche ich so die Erbsen auf der Stirn. Ich habe mir tatsächlich, ich habe mir, ich habe jetzt, diese Woche habe ich mal gesund gekocht. Also in einem Gefrierfach auch so Erbsen oder sowas für Verletzungen. Ja, genau. Oder so ein rohes Stück Fleisch. Einfach so schön und noch so ein schönes, nettes Calippo. Ja. Weil dann dann heißt es, okay, gut für die Stirn, gut für mich. Kann ich dann auch schön ablecken. Ich habe gekocht, schön mit Erbsen und Brokkoli, schönes Tiefkühlgemüse, hat mich nicht glücklich gemacht. Fehlt dir da was Ungesundes drin? Ja, mir fehlt was Ungesundes. Es ist so, ich weiß, dass es gesund ist und ich weiß, dass es mich gut fühlen lassen sollte, tut es nicht. Nee, da fehlt dann auch irgendwas, weil der Körper halt andere Sachen gewohnt ist. Ja, ich habe gehört, wenn man eine Tafel Schokolade isst, dann schüttet der Körper so Endorphine aus, dann geht's einem gut. Wo ich dachte, ja, dann haben wir es doch, oder? Ja, warum soll ich es lassen? Können wir doch hier da aufhören. Es macht dich literally glücklich, objektiv. Mir doch egal, ob es ungesund ist, es macht dich einfach... Also was ist denn wichtiger, gesund zu sein oder glücklich zu sein? Man kann so argumentieren, dass ein guter Gemütszustand tendenziell dazu führt, dass es dir besser geht, im Sinne auch eines gesundheitlichen Zustandes. Ja, Placebo. Ja, Placebo. Aber wenn ich die Wahl habe, will ich gesund sein oder will ich glücklich sein? Dann will ich doch glücklich sein. Also ist doch logisch ein Schlussfolgernd., die Schublade besser. Also ist doch logisch. Hast du das alte Conundrum gelöst? Hast du es gelöst? Wie wenn man das Wort ausspricht? Hast du es gelöst, was Conundrum auf Deutsch heisst? Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das Conundrum gelöst habe. Niemand kann es lösen. Hast du das alte Paradoxon gelöst?
Würde man nicht so übersetzen wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe es nicht gelöst, leider.
Viele noch offen ist ja tatsächlich...
Hast du auch Wünsche, für die du dich schämst manchmal?
Weil ich meine, es gibt ja, sag ich mal, Ziele, die kann man realistischerweise erreichen.
Jetzt zu sagen, keine Ahnung, du schreibst mal ein Drehbuch, das einen Oscar gewinnt oder so.
Das ist hochgegriffen, aber das kannst du durchaus schaffen. Du bist sehr begabt. Kannst du durchaus schaffen. Aber dass du jetzt, sagen wir mal, irgendwie nochmal in der Champions League als Spieler spielst. Eher unwahrscheinlich. Eher unwahrscheinlich. Wo man eher sagen würde, Stefan, jetzt mach dich mal nicht lächerlich. Wo Gander auf mich so nehmen würde und so Schwitzkasten geben würde. Dumme Idee. Idee. So die Hose runterziehen würde und du, Alter, du bist halt ein fucking halbgöttliches Wesen. Ich bin Hobbit. Ja, kann's halt. Warum musst du ein Haschloch sein? Das ist auch eine Verantwortung, lieber uns normalen Menschen. Mein Wunsch ist, und es ist unrealistisch, ich würde gerne eines dieser Millennium-Probleme lösen. Echter Wunsch. Das sind diese Mathe-Probleme. Ja, ich weiß. Die ungelösten Mathe-Probleme. Ungelösten, wo man eine Million Dollar kriegt und eine Fields-Medaille wahrscheinlich. Da würde ich gerne eins lösen. Vielleicht so die Riemann-Hypothese oder sowas. Ich habe mir die auch mal aufgemacht. Natürlich, jeder macht die sich mal auf. Und ich habe auch schon mal einen Zettel hingelegt im Stück. Ohne zu wissen. Ja, wo oben noch so der Einkaufszettel ist, wo man einfach so, ich ziehe eine Linie und die untere Hälfte benutze ich jetzt, um das Millennium-Problem zu lösen. Ich habe dann schon mal diese karierten Zettel genommen, ohne zu wissen, ob das Problem mit, ob ich karierte Kästchen brauche. Ja, ich war einkaufen und ich habe einen Karrietenblock und einen Blankoblock auch gekauft, weil ich nicht wusste, in welche Richtung die Forschorschweite schneiden. Millimeterpapier, weil ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ob das geometriert. Nee, aber das kennt man ja, weil das sind ja teilweise auch sehr theoretische Probleme, wo ich nicht genau weiß, ob man da was errechnen muss. Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß, ob man da einen Taschenreiner braucht. Aber so weit sind wir auch noch gar nicht. Nee, so seien wir nicht. Ich habe auch schon mal diese Seite aufgemacht, ich habe mir schon mal ein Zettel hingelegt, oben das Datum hingeschrieben und dann die Überschrift des Problems aufgeschrieben. Genau, und dann erst mal gegoogelt, was mache ich mit einer Million Dollar. Dann erst mal schauen, wie viele Ballistopackungen, wie viele so zwölfer Ballistopackungen kann ich mir für eine Million Dollar kaufen. Was ich liebe ist übrigens, krasse Autos konfigurieren. So auf Aston Martin und Org kann man ja dann auch in diesen K-Konfigurator eingeben, was man da will. Und dann gucken, wie kann man das in Aston Martin noch so upgraden, was gibt es da noch so? Das ist schon krass. Brauche ich, und dann überlegen, brauche ich wirklich so einen Wasseraufbereiter in der Yacht? Oder reicht nicht, ja gut, man kann einfach was einkaufen. Ja, vor allem die Yacht kostet zwei Millionen, der Wasseraufbereiter zwei hundert. Das wird jetzt, nimm ihn doch dazu. Macht das den Kohl fett,ohl fett? Nein, das macht den Kohl nicht fett. Macht das den Kohl fett. 200 Dollar Wasseraufbereiter, kein Problem. Und dann ist die andere Frage, da gibt es auch so eine Spüle, wo direkt kochendes Wasser rauskommt. Oh, das ist aber gefährlich, da kannst du die Hände verbrühen. Wenn die Kinder da rangehen? Ja gut, aber man kann es höher bauen vielleicht. Wie viel das kosten? Und dann geht man halt, da guckt man halt so, natürlich, jeder kennt das. Man lebt eigentlich schon dieses Leben und man hat, plötzlich hat man Probleme. Ja, aber was ist, wenn es dann zu hoch ist, dass ich nicht mehr rankomme, wenn ich den Fisch ja ausnehmen will? Und du bist nie zu Hause. Du bist nie zu Hause. Du bist die ganze Zeit nur im Casino. Ja, stimmt schon. Am Ende hast du richtig ernste Probleme. Erste Probleme, aber noch nie das Mal das Problem gelöst. Aber es gibt tatsächlich, ein bisschen traurig auch, aber es gibt tatsächlich das Phänomen, dass gerade in so grossen Supermärkten, so Walmarts oder so in den USA, dass dort die Mitarbeiter relativ häufig komplette Einkaufswägen wieder einräumen müssen. Weil es gibt anscheinend Leute, die in Armut gefallen sind, die nicht arm geworden sind, einfach rein und die da aber trotzdem noch einkaufen wollen, die dieses Gefühl einmal in der Woche gross einkaufen, nicht vermissen wollen und dann den Einkauf machen, aber halt dann nicht zahlen, weil sie kein Geld haben und dann lassen sie den Wagen einfach stehen. Aber sie wollen nicht darauf verzichten, diesen Einkauf zu machen, einfach um dieses Gefühl zu haben. Ich habe hier eine Kurzgeschichte gelesen von einer Autorin, die ich sehr empfinde kann, Samantha Schweblin. Wie kurz, wie viele Seiten? Nicht so viele Seiten, das war was für dich, fünf Seiten, zehn Seiten sowas. Und das ist eine argentinische Autorin und da ging es in der Kurzgeschichte darum, dass eine Mutter und die Tochter in reiche Gegenden fahren und sich da Häuser anzugucken und dann auch manchmal reingehen und so komischen Vorwänden und sowas. Und die Mutter legt sich dann auch in das Bett und sowas. Und ich habe es nicht genau verstanden, also aus europäischer Sicht macht es nicht so richtig Sinn. Da habe ich ja mal mit einem Argentiner gesprochen, der eigentlich meinte, ja, das ist schon einigermaßen ein bekanntes Phänomen, dass man auch mal gerne in reichere Viertel fährt, um sich da umzugucken. Das ist ja ein bisschen das Gleiche. Man will mal an dem Leben teilhaben. Mal gucken. Ist schon cool. Ich überlege auch mal in Köln. In Köln gibt es ja auch reichen Viertel, wo ich dachte, vielleicht fahre ich da einfach mal vorbei, guck mal in die Fenster. Ja, man weiss das ja gar nicht. Man weiss gar nicht, was der Markt so gibt. Ich hätte jetzt die Idee, mal zu gucken, wann Sperrmülltermine sind und dann so richtig krasse Villenviertel zu fahren. Und dann den Müll durchwühlen. Und dann einfach den Müll durchwühlen. Das ist dein Plan. Das ist mein Plan. Nein, nicht den Müll durchwühlen, aber so Theorie, These. Die werfen den Monadieser raus. Nee, aber so, die werfen so die guten Tonnetzstühle auf die Strasse. Oder mal, weiss nicht, ein krasses Designermöbelstück, den dänischen Armlehnenstuhl aus den 70er Jahren. Und du meinst, den werfen die einfach in die Mülltonne oder was? Nein, für den Sperrmüll stellen die nicht auf die Strasse, weil die sich einen neuen Sessel kaufen, weil jetzt doch der Corbusier-Sessel sein soll. Verstehst du? Meinst du wirklich, dass so richtig reiche Leute auf dem Niveau leben, dass sie Sachen auf die Strasse stellen und so? Ja. Oder rufen die nicht jemanden an und sagen, ja, hol dann die Stühle ab und wenn die neuen Stühle kommen, nimm die alten mit oder so? Aber super komfortabel. Ich weiß nicht, wie reiche Leute leben. Falls ihr reich seid, schreibt uns. Schreibt uns. Und schreibt mal so vielleicht, was macht ihr als reiche Menschen, von dem wir im Alltag profitieren können. Genau, oder was wir uns nicht vorstellen können. Oh, das finde ich übrigens mega. Lass uns mal den reichsten Podcast-UFO-Hörer finden. Das gab es doch bei, beim Neo Magazin gab es das doch, oder? Nee, bei Roche und Böhrmann. Hat der im Platz, ja, im Kontoauszug. Stimmt. Das machen wir jetzt. Wie viel hatte der denn? Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Der hatte ein paar hunderttausend, glaube ich, oder? Aber es war jetzt nicht so viel, wo ich dachte, das ist crazy viel. Aber haben reiche Menschen ihr Geld denn so auf einem Konto? Eigentlich nicht, oder? Die haben das doch irgendwo angelegt. Aber die können es ja kurz mal umschichten für uns. Für den krassen Screenshot. Ich möchte wissen, wer ist der reichste Podcast-UFO-Hörer? Ja, und die Leute schicken uns jetzt irgendwie gefakte Screenshots oder was?
Und ich möchte, dass der reichste Podcast-Ufo-Hörer dem ärmsten Podcast-Ufo-Hörer 10.000 Euro überweist.
Das tut ihm ja gar nicht weh.
Ja gut, aber jetzt irgendwie einen Screenshot von seinem Konto mit 15 Cent zu schicken, kannst du auch faken, oder?
Wie finden wir den ärmsten Podcast-Ufo-Zuhörer?
Ja, vor allem so arm kann er ja gar nicht sein.
Er muss ja irgendwie einen Zugang haben zu Podcasts.
Handy muss er haben mit Screenshot.
Lass uns, ich würde, lass uns erst mal, also wer wirklich reich ist,
mich würde interessieren, so was ihr macht, was wir uns nicht vorstellen können,
so dass irgendwie so was, ja, was können wir uns nicht vorstellen?
Das ist meine Frage an dich, an euch, was können wir uns nicht vorstellen?
Das ist vielleicht die beste Frage, die er uns gestellt hat. Ja, aber ich habe auch mal so gehört, dass irgendwie so eine reiche Bank oder so hat irgendwie so ein grosses Meeting gemacht, irgendwie so ein Jahrestag von irgendwas und als Location haben die ein komplettes Museum einfach gebucht. Die haben einfach gesagt, das nehmen wir für einen Tag und dann haben die einfach so Tische und Stühle aufgestellt in den Ausstellungsräumen und haben da halt einfach dann irgendwie auch gegessen und getrunken und da halt ihre Feier gemacht, in einem Museum einfach, wo ich mir auch dachte, wow, da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen. Ich dachte, die haben okay, vielleicht so ein Luxushotel oder so, aber dass die einfach sagen, nee, das Museum, dann stehen die halt da so Ritterrüstungen um die rum und halt so alte Gemälde, was halt eine coole Atmosphäre ist für so ein Ding. Aber solche Sachen hätte ich gern. Ja, du musst halt irgendwie von deinem traurigen Bankalltag ja auch fliehen. Weil wenn du das Tag bist, bist du halt einfach Banker, ist auch lame. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also Wolf of Wall Street sah schon cool aus. Lame! Wie viele Leute haben nach... Gandalf sagt, lame! Ja, halbgöttlicher Zauberer, sein ist cooler. Ja, sind wir halt nicht, wir sind Bauern. Wir bauen halt Kürbisse an. Lame. Aber wie viele Leute haben nach Wolf of Wall Street so eine Banklehre angefangen und wirklich wo der Banklehrer-Leitung, Schulungsleiter sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt 500 Prozent der normalen Banklehrlinge. Leute, es ist nicht, wie es ihr hier vorstellt. Ich glaube wirklich, dass Filme sehr dafür stehen, also ich glaube, das auch, wie man jetzt beim Schach merkt, Queen's Gambit ist ja einfach auch dafür verantwortlich für den Schach. Ich glaube, dass es immer so ist, dass es so Wellen gibt von Filmen. Ich glaube auch zum Beispiel, dass nach Breaking Bad, als so die Studenten in Chemie oder so sich verdreifacht haben, weil alle dachten, wie cool ist das denn?
Wir können Dinge explodieren, wir können Gangster umbringen, wir können Drogen bauen. Wir können Drogen bauen. Aber ich glaube, das ist schon so, dass man dann sehr beeinflusst war. Aber auch alle Menschen dann immer, das sehen die jetzt und dann wollen die es direkt machen. So bin ich aber auch, das verstehe ich auch, finde ich auch gut. Finde ich auch gut. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, wo dein Talent dich noch hintreibt und welches Genre du nächste Woche dominieren wirst, ob du dann einfach der beste Pianist der Welt bist, weil du mal irgendwie in einem Stream so nebenbei geklimpert hast und einfach lang, lang sagt, naja, das ist für mich einfach der begabteste Pianist der Geschichte. Aber in wie vielen Kategorien muss ich das hinkriegen, bis ich einfach als der talentösste Mensch der Welt gelte? Ich glaube vier. Bei bis drei ist noch Goethe. Goethe hat gemalt, hat eine Farblehre gemacht und geschrieben. Das sind drei. Unser Erzfeind Da Vinci, die Sau, hängt da auch mit in der Kette. Fucking, fucking, fucking Da Vinci! Ja, Bixer. Naja, kriegst du schon hin, schaffst du schon. Ich wünsche dir eine schöne Woche. Ich wün ich wünsche dir auch eine schöne Woche. Geniess in deinem Ruhm. Ich genieße noch kurz meinen Ruhm. Entschuldigt mich für diese arrogante Kackfolge. Ich bleibe jetzt noch ein bisschen auf diesem Höhenflug geschweben. Ihr seht mich da oben rumfliegen, bis ich dann irgendwann wieder sanften Fusses lande. Oder abstürze, das kann auch passieren, weiß ich noch nicht genau. Genieß es es, geniesse die Woche, ich wünsche dir eine ganz tolle Woche für euch.
Dankeschön, ich dir auch und ich würde sagen, ich würde mich gerne an dich ranhängen und einmal mit dir nach oben fliegen.
Ich hebe jetzt ab.
Okay.
The worst by Brutchen.